it has been a week since your big reveal
on the mast singer
what has the reaction from your friends
and fans been like it's been insane I'm
being stalked everywhere like you and I
find myself like doing my little Rico
like unicorn like hey like I'm like oh
my gosh um the kids like it's so
interesting like generations you know my
kids are 11 to 23 months and you know
902 and oh they're like what's that but
the masked singer like now in school
they come home like mom you're famous
now I love it like you know it's awesome
what has Jenny's reaction and Luke's
reaction have any of your 902 a know of
co-stars reached out to you since the
big reveal they have and they're like oh
my gosh you didn't tell us your I was
like I couldn't tell anyone
you are the Unicorn and I love that
because we all have kids now and their
kids are watching it so it's pretty cool
last talked with you you said that
you're hard at work out on the 902 a no
reboot what's the status right now how
many of your co-stars are coming back is
Shannon coming back so I can't really
say anything at the moment but um we're
all really excited to get back to work
and to work together it's like family
coming back together you know it really
is it's like the ultimate high school
reunion except at high school reunions
you're like oh my gosh I haven't seen
you in so many years and then the night
ends and you move on like we actually
get to like be together again so it's
full circle
[Music]